research project turned into a much
price search engine it is called Google
your amount of information available is
immense at Google our mission is to make
the world's information accessible and
useful Larry Page CEO of alphabet Sergey
Brin president of the company stepping
down from their roles
on August 10 2015 Larry Page and Sergey
Brannon made it Sundar piche the CEO of
Google at first glance it seemed like
the duo just wanted to play a more
hands-off role at the company while
Sunder handled all of the day-to-day
nuances of running Google Larry and
Sergey could focus on the long-term
future of the company but just four
years later in December of 2019 Barry
and Sergey would make Sunder the CEO of
alphabet itself and they would more or
less Fall Off the Grid completely they
rarely make any public appearances and
they're notorious for skipping meetings
this is quite out of the blue given that
most Founders tend to play a significant
role in their companies until the day
they die I mean just look at Warren
Buffett or Charlie Munger Larry and
Sergey however have truly left the
company and the spotlight despite still
having 51 control of the company this is
a pretty bold move given that their end
entire fortunes depend on the
performance of Google if you ask them it
directly they'll tell you that it was
time to assume the role of proud parents
offering advice and love but not daily
nagging but if you take a closer look
you'll see that there's more to this
than they let on it's not that Larry and
Sergey don't have visions for Google or
that they don't want to leave the
company rather they've found that every
time they try to take the reins of the
company investors aren't particularly
happy and this wasn't the one or two
Time Event it was a consistent theme
throughout their entire time at Google
and it seems that eventually they came
to accept that the goals of Google and
their own goals simply didn't not align
and instead of trying to resist they did
The Classy thing and it truly stepped
away so here's the truth behind why
Google's Founders really ditched to
Google and never looked back
while Larry and Sergey didn't leave till
recent years their unorthodox leadership
style was evident from day one likely
one of the best examples of this was
Larry's workplace rule book which
consisted of five roles rule number one
was don't delegate do everything you can
yourself to make things go faster this
is quite ironic given that you could
argue that Larry himself is breaking
this rule today putting that aside
though effective delegation within any
business is extremely important but
Larry was actively encouraging employees
to specifically avoid delegation moving
on to rule number two we have it don't
get in the way if you're not adding
value lots of people are actually doing
the work talk to each other while you go
do something else rule number three was
don't be a bureaucrat rule number four
was ideas that are more important than
an age just because someone is Junior
doesn't mean that they don't deserve
respect and cooperation and finally rule
number five was the worst thing you can
do is stop someone from doing something
by saying it no period if you say no you
have to help them find a better way to
get it done while many of these roles do
make sense Larry's motivation for these
rules weren't exactly pure you see it
Larry wasn't not trying to create a
Harmony between managers and Engineers
rather he was trying to completely
eliminate managers altogether because he
did not like the idea of a non-engineer
supervising Engineers he found that this
supervision was not only unnecessary but
also an impediment Larry was extremely
confident in the quality of his
engineering hires and he felt that there
was no reason for them to be babysit
hence the rulebook Larry was hoping that
the rule book would keep managers out of
the hairs of Engineers but with the time
he came to realize that this wasn't the
case and he became more and more
irritated one of the factors that pushed
him over the edge was the fact that he
wasn't seeing any progress on his book
searching idea Larry wanted Google to be
able to scan all the books and the world
and then make them searchable online
you're probably familiar with this
feature today but this wasn't going well
and I don't think you'd be surprised to
hear that he blamed the project managers
instead of holding a meeting with the
managers like a reasonable CEO though he
would hold a tunnel stop meeting with
all of the managers and engineers in
July of 2001. he would go on to insult
all the managers in front of everyone
before firing them all to Larry surprise
though this didn't get anyone fired
except himself as you were to guess the
project managers were not happy with
this choice for obvious reasons but it
wasn't just the project managers that
were unhappy one engineer even yelled at
Larry declaring that what he was doing
was completely ridiculous and totally
unprofessional Google's Human Resources
boss Stacey Sullivan would escalate this
issue to the chairman of Google Eric
Schmidt who had been placed there by
Google's investors Eric would of course
side with the managers and that this
resulted in it in most of the managers
reinstated and Larry being demoted from
being CEO Eric would take on this
brawler so that he could supervise Larry
and Sergey and let's just say Larry was
very unhappy
fortunately for Eric he didn't have to
do too much babysitting over the next
several years because Larry and Sergey
did it not poke around too much when it
came to the operations of Google instead
they focused on Acquisitions which they
knocked out of the park first they had
the Android acquisition in 2005 which
cost Google 50 million dollars Larry
actually completed this acquisition
without even telling Eric but he didn't
mind from Eric's perspective Google was
already a 100 billion dollar company and
if a mere 50 million could keep Larry
occupied it and prevent him from making
any more rash choices at Google that was
a major win and that's exactly what
happened over the next few years Larry
and Sergey would be enthralled with
making a bunch of Acquisitions and to
their credit many of their Acquisitions
proved to be extremely successful like
YouTube aside from Acquisitions these
two were also super busy with what they
like to call the moonshot factory likely
the two most famous inventions out of
this Factory are the Google self-driving
car and Google Glass pretty soon it Eric
began to feel that he could trust these
two once again not only were they making
phenomenal Acquisitions and the
groundbreaking Innovations but they
weren't doing anything that was too
questionable either they weren't
insulting employees in front of each
other nor were they firing at every
manager in the company it seemed like
the duo had matured as Business Leaders
and shareholders very much agreed so in
2011 when Eric stepped on SEO he would
pass on the title to Larry but it didn't
take long for everyone to realize that
nothing had changed for Larry or Sergey
they had simply found an outlet for
their unorthodox ideas with Acquisitions
and the moonshot factory but now that
Larry was back to running Google proper
many of the same issues started to
resurface once again
foreign
for Larry seems to be that he simply
doesn't not like oversight in general
originally he didn't like managers
overseeing Engineers but that was before
Google went public now that Google was
public one of his largest concerns was
investor oversight of Google but he
wasn't gonna immediately try to tackle
that issue the reason he got screwed a
decade ago was because the employees
weren't on his side so this time he was
going to make sure that investors were
on his side before he tried anything too
radical and this started with giving
investors what they wanted most
sustainable growth Larry started off by
slashing Google's products features and
services apparently he reduced these by
70 within just two years of taking over
he also placed an emphasis on design and
simplicity trying to emulate some of
Apple's success within that realm and
finally Larry also implemented a new
constraint for Acquisitions called the
toothbrush test instead of looking at
their profitability or financials of a
given company Google evaluated these
companies based on their usefulness
alone if a company offers something that
people will use once or twice per day
and it makes their life better the
company is a winner if it doesn't do
that however Larry wouldn't buy the
company even if they had tremendous
financials while this was definitely on
the side of unorthodox it worked
Google's revenue was growing their
profits were growing and most
importantly their stock price was
growing investors were starting to trust
Hillary but it didn't take very long for
him to take things too far once again
with Google Island if you haven't heard
about Google Island it was essentially
Larry's idea to take Google off the
gradient not necessarily physically but
metaphorically he wanted Google to have
freedom from not only investors but also
government regulation one of his
proposed ideas was that laws older than
50 years wouldn't apply to tech
companies TechCrunch put it as Larry
wanting the Earth to have a mad
scientist Island that was run by Google
while this may sound cool in Theory it
was also unrealistic Google Island would
not only free Google from some of the
barriers of innovation but it would also
free them from accountability altogether
if neither the government nor investors
could keep Google accountable who would
obviously Larry believed that he could
keep Google accountable but this was
more of a pipe dream than anything after
pitching this idea dozens of
Publications would ruthlessly bag on
Larry claiming that he was completely
out of touch from reality and almost all
of them pose the same question is this
the type of guy you wanted to be in
charge of Google
no one would fire Larry from his
position the second time around but
Larry himself had come to a realization
Google wouldn't never be what he wanted
it to be this isn't to say that Google
wouldn't be successful or that it
wouldn't make a boatload of money
because it's done both of those but what
this did mean though is that Google
wouldn't never become a groundbreaking
research institution which is what
alarion Sergey wanted from day one the
thing to keep in mind is that Larry and
Sergey were never your traditional Tech
Founders they weren't your classic
College dropouts who wanted to change
their world and to become Mega Rich they
were actually PhD students who founded
Google as a research project and while
they were all for the financial side of
Google they didn't want for Google to
lose its identity as a research
institution either but with time it was
clear that investors didn't really care
about this unless it could directly be
linked to profits at the same time both
Larry and Sergey were both facing
significant personal challenges as well
Larry had been struggling with the vocal
cord paralysis for much of his adult
life and that things were only getting
worse in the early 2010s this made it
especially difficult for Larry to engage
in interviews and earn his calls and
other PR events which are extremely
important for any public company CEO
this made it Larry Infamous for being
the Mia CEO meanwhile Sergey had gotten
caught up in an affair which not only
ruined his public reputation but also
his relationship with Larry because
refused to speak to him since given that
Larry and Sergey have 51 voting power at
Google they could technically take
Google in whatever Direction they wanted
but given that they only owned about 14
of their company together I think it was
pretty clear to them that abusing their
voting power would be a pretty douchey
thing to do to the other 86 percent of
shareholders so they would decided to do
The Classy thing and to give
shareholders what they wanted they gave
the shareholders a CEO that could grow
Google into a multi-trillion dollar
company Sundar piche in the meantime
Larry and Sergey have ventured off into
what they've always wanted to do
research exciting ideas like flying cars
and anti-aging it and hopefully bring
them to fruition and that's why Google's
Founders really left Google do you think
Google would be better under Larry and
sergey's Leadership comment that down
below also drop a like if you hope that
Google does not forget their slogan
don't be evil and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
suggest for everybody ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then hurry
and I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]